et voilà il a fait s'impliquant près
sérieuse au piano pour s'étonner que ces
lampes ionis il est très sérieux très
sérieux c'est vrai on s'imagine que
c'est un farfelu pas du tout moi je le
connais depuis 20 ans à l'époque c'était
un des meilleurs joueurs de billard de
paris il est mais c'est vrai il était
sportif qui joue la pelote basque est un
champion de pelote basque au sida riche
des bijoux et en dessus doit c'est pas
vrai mais il est modeste il ne n'iras
pas danser vos du sport et puis l'a28 du
pèlerin dans la natation était terrible
aussi ce qu'il faut genevière voilà je
vous dis un truc au moment de la
traversée de wagon isolé je suis allé
parce que j'ai fait ça quand j'étais
tout jeune je lève ça si tu veux te
voilà je me baisse les lots non parce
que considérant considérant que
lorsqu'on est jeune dans la vie pour
réussir il faut se mouiller à 20 ans je
me suis mis à l'eau parce que je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que j'étais le
premier à traverser à la nage
allez allez de calais à new york à la
nage
c'est le premier alors je vais vous lire
tous les jours sur mon petit carnet de
bord mon petit livre de bord j'écrivais
les l'impression que je ressentais au
cours de cette odyssée j'en ai redit
alors ça j'ai déjà dit zahia il ya deux
ans mais c'est pas grave moi ça me plaît
bien
alors qu'à l'est 6 décembre 016 je
rentre dans l'autre doucement agra agro
aggrava zoah va mon dieu qu'elle est
froide 017 l'eau rentre dans les trous
de nez 6 février 016 jeune âge depuis
deux mois et est déjà parcouru 1947 km
je décide alors d'enlever mes chaussures
car elle commence à prendre l'eau qui
février jeune âge 15 février jaune à 16
février jeune âge des débris jeune âge
le vivrier jeune âge mahdi avait brillé
jeune âge
22 février là ça change d'une seconde
heureusement que je sais nager 40 5
février
je fatigue et comme j'ai un stylo je
jette l'ancré d'autre part comme la mer
est calme je décide de faire la planche
ce but à ce moment que je vise un
poisson 6 me regarder goulûment alors je
lui ai fait des gros yeux et il est
parti j'aime qu'on l'asie pour me faire
scier aulas je vous en prie je vous en
prie quelles sont ces rumeurs en avant
mon linge je me suis fait une grosse
ampoule à la main
chouette je vais pouvoir lire cette nuit
59 février je continue à faire mais si
nos valeurs ce qui fait que nageur
depuis 1884 1323 heures je me trouve en
possession de 5 millions de 145 1938 ne
dont je ne sais pas quoi foudre d'autre
part la jante fait d'autre part les
femmes commence à me manquer bougrement
60 ans évrier la gente féminine ne
mordent de plus en plus une femme
banlieue 80 février jeunes ampli plus
haineuse et où donner de la tête
c'est une image 83 évrier jeu devient
littéralement sol f
là la jeune ans je deviens complètement
sol et commence à faire des rêves cochon
j'en profite pour hisser le grand foc 94
février je délire jeune fille plus
seigneur au secours
je veux une femme seigneur au secours
c'est pour ça vous savez c'est bon ça
attention c'est beaux-arts 95 février
enfin ça y est merci seigneur je suis
exaucé car je me suis fait une rue en
plein milieu et ça veut me va beaucoup
mieux sans 13 février je me pèse 6 kg
400 je commence à m'inquiéter
encore un kilo de moins et ma mère va se
retrouver enceinte elle va découvrir
y'a pas de quoi mais vous avez de la
patience alors 24 mars
il ne me reste plus que 800 mètres à
parcourir pour arriver à new york
mais comme je suis fatigué je décide de
retourner à calais voilà